économie environnement énergie eau
sociale le développement durable à la
Réunion c'est
maintenant je suis Valentine je
participe à l'activité environnement qui
a lieu tous les Lund midi au collège
nous y aménageons depuis quelques années
des espac verts et pour améliorer le
cadre de vie du collège plutôt que
d'acheter les plantes nous essayons de
les produire nous-mêm soit en semement
soit en bouturant nous allons vous
montrer comment obtenir une plante par
bouturage pour faire une bouture il faut
un sac orticole rempli d'un mélange de
terreau et de
compost une branche d'une vingtaine de
centimètres dépourvu de la plupart de
ces feuilles pour empêcher les pertes en
eau il faut la couper
horizontalement à la base puis la couper
en
biseau de l'autre
côté il suffit de la planter dans la
dans le sol en y mettant deux ou trois
nœuds il reste plus qu'à arroser et
voilà ce que ça donne une fois que la
bouture a
pris après 3 6 mois
la bouture peut-être plantée l'intérêt
des sac orticol est que la plante est
mise en terre avec la motte ainsi les
racines ne sont pas cassées et la plante
ne subit aucun dommage il suffit alors
d'arroser abondamment ensuite il faut
savoir être patient et attendre que la
plante grandisse et donne ses premières
Faur je peux économiser jusqu'à 400 €
sur mes consommation d'essence comment
pour les courtes distances je privilégie
la marche ou le vélo si j'ai plusieurs
kilomètres à parcourir j'utilise au
maximum le covoiturage ou les transports
en commun si je suis contraint
d'utiliser ma voiture j'adopte une
conduite souple et je roule à allure
modérée je réserve l'usage de la
climatisation au long trajet
j'entretiens mon véhicule régulièrement
je coupe le moteur de mon véhicule quand
je suis à l'arrêt pendant plus d'une
minute alors vous voyez préserver
l'environnement c'est augmenter votre
pouvoir d'achat le Conseil Général agit
pour le développement durable et
vous
économie environnement énergie eau
sociale le développement durable à la
Réunion c'est
maintenant